avec nous pour en parler
mourad pardon amour président de
l'association agir association des
juristes formation et réparation pour
les harkis vous êtes ancien maire de
volvic vous êtes également fils de harki
vous avez d'ailleurs écrit plusieurs
livres sur ce sujet dans cet ouvrage de
référence et ils sont devenus harkis aux
éditions fayard bonsoir aimera donne à
vous et merci d'être avec nous à vos
côtés mohamed k qui vous êtes fondateur
de l'association mémorielle les oranges
et on le rappelle vous êtes co rédacteur
en 2015 d'un appel pour la
reconnaissance des crimes coloniaux par
la france en algérie merci à tous les
deux d'avoir accepté notre invitation
on a entendu une réaction plutôt
positive du petit fils qui salue donc
une avancée vers la vérité la
réconciliation mohamed kaki votre
réaction à ce geste
aujourd'hui emmanuel macron l'utc c'est
une bonne nouvelle
c'est un pas important dans un processus
est un processus à partir duquel le
rapport de benjamin stora d'une part
mais aussi les revendications des
associations comme les oranges sur ce
travail mémoriel important dans le but
de créer les conditions de la réussite
d'un d'une nouvelle relation entre la
france et l'algérie
donc moi je salue cette cette nouvelle
jeu parce que c'est important en plus
les conditions dans lesquelles elle
s'est faite c'est à dire qu'il a reçu la
famille et comme la famille odin
d'ailleurs il a été chez eux et je
trouve que ça c'est un acte d'humanité
important il faut le reconnaître quand
il ya des bonnes choses il faut les
reconnaître cependant ce n'est pas
suffisant ce n'est pas suffisant parce
que nous on souhaite c'est que
la guerre d'algérie soit qualifié comme
crime contre l'humanité parce qu'il ya
eu des choses terribles et pas seulement
entre le 1er novembre 1954 et 1962 mais
depuis le début de la colonisation
depuis 1830 et notamment avec le
sinistre individu que vous connaissez
qui est le général bugeaud pour lequel
d'ailleurs nous avons fait avec olivier
le cour grandmaison et l'association les
oranges une pétition importante que nous
avons lancée pour le retrait des rues et
des plaques et surtout des statuts en
france de ce sinistre individu qui a été
l'ennemi de la république d'une part
puisqu'il a voulu réinstaurer la
monarchie et d'autres peurs qui a écrasé
aussi la commune est évidemment il a tué
de très nombreuses algérie la réaction
tout d'abord à ce geste de mots rendent
à vous comment vous qualifieriez ce
geste emmanuel macron aujourd'hui me
rendais à nouveau je crois que c'est un
geste qui s'inscrit dans sa volonté de
tenir un discours de vérité sur cette
période
quand il faut revenir à la commande de
ce rapport ce pour à la commande était
clair cp2 car l état des lieux juste et
précis ce qui a pu a dit fier de ce
qu'il reste à faire est également de
travailler à l'apaisement à l'apaisement
et la sérénité ce sont les propres
termes de la lettre avec de commande à
l'égard de tout ce que ça n'était cette
histoire avec cette guerre a meurtri
donc il y avait à la fois vouloir
réconcilier si c'était exact en fait en
tout cas d'améliorer les relations entre
la france et l'algérie par un discours
de vérité
nello de réconcilier des populations
françaises qui ont été meurtris par
cette guerre ce choix
les harkis qui soit les pieds noirs les
appeler et que ce point de vue ce que je
veux dire c'est qu'évidemment on ne peut
que saluer tous les gestes de vérité
historique il faut pas que ce soit un
simple sud et puis c'est à dire que pour
l'instant si on veut
réconciliation il faut que les deux le
veuille et que les deux fesses il n'est
pas dans le sens il faut aussi que
l'algérie
or qu un regard lucide alors regard
critique sur son histoire et qu'elle
reconnaisse elle aussi un certain nombre
de crimes au milieu de cette guerre et
notamment les massacres de l'art qui est
notamment les enlèvements les
disparitions de civils après
l'indépendance oui on rêvait cac est
votre réponse il faut que les deux pays
reconnaissent leurs responsabilités
écoutez la balle est d'abord dans le
camp de la france il faut quand même
rappeler ce qu'a fait la france et
notamment puisqu'on a parlé de ali
boumendjel il y a eu des centaines de
milliers de ali boumendjel qui ont été
torturés qui ont été assassinés
froidement dans le cadre d'une commande
politique à l'époque et donc ça aussi
c'est important et j'ajoute d'ailleurs
que le président macro lui même avait
reconnu que c'était un crime contre
l'humanité qui avait été fait contre le
peuple algérien et donc qui a créé tout
un malheur dont les harkis sont aussi
d'une certaine manière les victimes
puisque c'est la colonisation qui est un
véritable poison qui a créé et qui a
disloqué le peuple algérien dans en
mille morceaux
et effectivement c'est là qu'il faut
revenir pour requalifier la chose en
crimes contre l'humanité et ça c'est
important nous enverrons d'ailleurs sur
la question du rapport de benjamin stora
que d'une part je salue mais qui en même
temps je nuancerais puisqu'il ya des
choses sur lesquelles nous ne sommes pas
d'accord sur par exemple la
qualification d'un certain nombre de
mots quand il parle d' exactions quand
il parle de répression
alors qu'il s'agit de massacre de crime
d'état terrible où on affame et les
populations
vous savez chaque algérien a aujourd'hui
une mémoire meurtrie extrêmement
importante
alors évidemment
il faudra aussi dans un deuxième temps
puisque là c'est le regard d'un
historien français il faut aussi qu'ils
aient les historiens algériens face
aussi ce travail puisse le faire et dans
des bonnes conditions
évidemment ensuite il faut joindre les
deux bouts et voir comment mais il n'y a
pas de possibilité de se réconcilier
totalement sur deux souligné que ce
rapport là il met pas tout le monde
d'accord ils créent même la polémique
est minimale le débat je vous pose
regarder cette lune non les céréales et
justement à cette tribune
mohand hamoumou nounou fille et femme
d'heure qui est récusons le rapport
stora sur la guerre d'algérie
elle a été un peu oublié cette tribune
dans les colonnes du figaro il ya un
mois regardez le rapport de stora sur
les questions mémorielles portant sur la
colonisation et la guerre d'algérie
obéit à des considérations politiques et
non historique au préjudice de la vérité
sur les harkis fils de harki une
réaction j'ai fait la nouvelle sur home
solaire qui sait à ce titre là c'est
intéressant d'avoir l'avis ont compté
que c'est ce que vient de dire on
coulait c'est compliqué la
réconciliation parce que vous dites il
ya eu effectivement des milliers de
comédienne probablement mais il ya eu
aussi des dizaines de milliers de harkis
qui étaient des civils et leurs familles
s'ils ont été massacrés dans des
conditions horribles
après les accords d'evian qui était
censé garantir la sécurité des biens et
des personnes
si on veut la vérité il la faut il la
faut des deux côtés on ne peut pas sans
arrêt revenir sur les crimes
effectivement commis pendant la période
coloniale et ne pas vouloir voir ce qui
s'est passé après les accords d'evian le
dialogue n'était pas encore sèche que le
sang coulait déjà fait désolé il faut
aussi que l'algérie importe ce regard
lucide et critique sur son histoire
les algériens eux-mêmes aujourd'hui sans
doute probablement envie on arrête avec
cette histoire
au mystifiante mythifié qui évidemment
tout à la gloire du fln et qui cache non
seulement le massacre des harkis mais
aussi les massacres de mai sa liste et
bassac 2012 à mais certainement deux
dirigeants ont été éliminés il faut
parler plus influent de la vérité
historique sur ce rapport
un maître kaki on obéit
dans ce rapport à des considérations
plutôt politique et non historique
écoutez moi je crois qu'il faut pas être
naïf
on y lit à un contexte dans lequel ces
cris ce rapport d'une part il ya un
contexte dans lequel ce rapport est
remis
je vous rappelle qu'on est à un an des
élections nationales et qu'il ya des
enjeux extrêmement important 1 mais est
évidemment qu'il ya des manques il y a
des choses importantes il ya aussi des
lobbys un lobby de l'oes voyez monsieur
le collègue parle aussi de d'un certain
nombre d'intérêts qui est celui des
harkis qui effectivement dont il faudra
parler bien sûr mais qui est dans un
contexte de conditions de production
historiques et que dont le peuple après
il appartient aux historiens algériens
aussi de dire lors mou il appartient
aussi au peuple algérien je pense qu'il
faut pas parler à la place des gens et
ça c'est sait quelque chose
alors évidemment on n'est pas naïfs
puisque aujourd'hui ce rapport notamment
sur la rhétorique sémantique un an je
vous parlais tout à l'heure c'est à dire
exactions accès
il ya des tendances à minimiser le drame
terrible qui a vécu le peuple algérien
et ses seins et ça c'est important
alors il ya eu des avancées comme je
vous le disais tout à l'heure mais il
suffirait simplement que le président de
la république française puisse dire
clairement que c'est un un crime contre
l'humanité et que du coup on peut
repartir sur de bonnes bases
alors évidemment je
bien que du côté qui a une critique à
faire aussi du côté algérien mais bien
sûr mais ça il faut que les uns et les
autres travaillent là dessus mais la
question des harkis
c'est une question importante mais elle
est aussi a été elle émerge dans les
conditions de l'histoire coloniale
c'est à dire que ni de vase est
sincèrement qu'il faut le rappeler la
loi de la faim pendant la réponse ce que
j'aime bien c'est que une fois de plus
j'ai tenu à rappeler le contexte ce
rapport je crois qu'elle est l'objectif
objectif c'est de vouloir à la fois
améliorer la relation qu'elle jouit en
faisant des gestes effectivement les
reconnaissances de vérité mais c'est
aussi reconsidérer les mémoires de
blessés deux des populations françaises
les à les appeler les arcs et des pieds
noirs et autres
hélas deux sur cinq vit là il faut aussi
que le président de la république
poursuivre sa démarche c'est à dire que
reconnaître effectivement l'assassinât
de maurice audin coûte à des bouts de
match est très bien mais il faut aussi
que la france reconnaisse pas qu'elle a
abandonné les harkis parce que si
effectivement en algérie les a
assassinés
c'est aussi parce que l'armée française
et les gouvernements des banques surtout
parce que c'est le gouvernement qui
décide des pas l'armée ont donné l'ordre
de ne pas rapatrier les harkis ou très
peu et donc il va bien falloir
reconnaître sa reconnaître cette
responsabilité ce qu'est ce qu'on fait
d'ailleurs allé président chirac sarkozy
et hollande en dix ans reconnaît la
responsabilité de l'état dans l'abandon
des harkis et dont ils font que
officiellement que ce soit reconnue
aujourd'hui le président de la
république paru noir et qu'après
effectivement l'algérie fasse aussi son
travail de reconnaissance effectivement
les massacres qui ont eu lieu
et à ce moment là on comprend que ce
dont on a besoin que dans les nouvelles
générations
c'est pas d'excusés c'est pas trop
content c'est de vérité c'est sur la
vérité qui pourra bâtir un avenir mieux
ça sera demande la fin merci à tous les
deux mornes amont nous
m kalki d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur arte france